if you look at if you look at public
statements like you can you can find Sam
Altman specifically saying
there's a good chance that this kills
everyone
right I I mean I don't that's not like a
direct quote
um but I think he said you know the the
bad outcome is lights out for everyone
or something like that welcome back
ladies and gentlemen to the machine
learning Street Talk YouTube channel and
podcast where we bring you the brightest
minds and the latest insights into the
field of artificial intelligence now
today we're absolutely thrilled to have
with us an extraordinary individual
who's been pushing the boundaries of our
understanding of AI and its potential
impacts on our lives Robert Miles
now Robert is a renowned artificial
intelligence Advocate researcher and
YouTube sensation whose unique mix of
engaging discussions and entertaining
content has captured the interest of
thousands or even millions of viewers
around the world
do we have a backup plan well this turns
out to be a really hard problem how do
you design a training process that
reliably differentiates between things
that are true and things that you think
are true when you yourself can't
differentiate between those two things
kind of by definition this is an active
area of study in AI alignment research
and I'll talk about some approaches to
Framing and tackling this problem in
later videos now with a strong
background in computer science Robert
has been actively involved in various AI
safety projects and has dedicated
himself to raising awareness about the
potential risks and benefits of advanced
AI systems
his YouTube channel is widely recognized
for making AI safety discussion
accessible to a diverse Audience by
breaking down complex topics into easy
to understand nuggets of knowledge
now many of you will know Robert from
his appearances on computer file I've
been a huge fan of Robert for many many
years now and I'm so excited that we've
got him on mlst now in today's episode
we're going to be diving deep into
Robert's journey into the world of AI
exploring his insights on alignment
super intelligence the role of AI in
shaping our society and indeed the
future
this podcast is sponsored by numerite a
groundbreaking platform that's taking
the data Science World by storm I've
been using numeri to build
state-of-the-art models which predict
the stock market or while being part of
an inspiring community of data
scientists from around the globe
they host the numeroid data science
tournament where data scientists like us
use their obfuscated financial data set
to predict future stock market
performance
now the unique aspect about the
tournament is that it runs weekly rounds
with each round spanning a month every
week starting from Saturday to Friday
there are four stages open closed
scoring and resolved and throughout we
get to work with numerized clean
pre-processed data which describes the
global stock market over time
now this data set is tabular with each
row representing stock at a particular
point in time and our primary objective
is to build machine learning models to
predict the target variable which
represents a measure of future returns
now the best part is we get scored on
our predictions based on parameters like
correlation and true contribution and
not only that we can stake NMR which has
memorized very own cryptocurrency on our
models which allows us to earn payouts
based on our performance a positive
score means we earn a payout while a
negative score could lead to a portion
of our stake getting burned
now numeroi even has a leaderboard which
ranks US based on our model's one-year
average reputation score
so not only do we get a chance to earn
rewards but we also have an opportunity
to measure our skills against the very
best data scientists in the world
competing in numerized tournament has
been an amazing way for me to sharpen my
data science skills I couldn't recommend
it enough to my fellow data scientists
and enthusiasts if this intrigues you
head over to numerai and join in this
exciting journey in revolutionizing the
financial world through the power of
data science now let's get back to
today's podcast I bring you Robert Miles
[Music]
Robert is one of the main faces I think
associated with the alignment movement
and definitely one of one of the most
credible voices as well because I think
he's just so good at communication and
kind of making these Concepts
understandable to people but um Robert
maybe you could just kick off and just
give us a clear definition of alignment
one which can be consistently applied
across different AI systems and contexts
yeah so first off I want to say I
have been oversold here
um I think I'm reasonable I'm reasonably
good at explaining things if I have days
to sit down and write a script and then
read that script uh let's see how we do
ad-lib
um so so the way I think about alignment
is
uh basically if you have ai systems that
want something
it's aligned if what it wants is the
same thing as what you want
it's you know like that's the simplest
the simplest way I could frame it
um
and so
it's important to note that it's not
it's not that it wants the set it's not
that it wants the same thing that you
want
uh for itself it's that it's preference
ordering over World States is the same
as yours so it will choose outcomes that
are what you would want to happen
okay okay so in which case I'm
interested to know what a good solution
to AI alignment would look like but you
know a super intelligence which actually
understands and agrees with are deeply
held human values and morality
um would that then mean it would just
cure cancer and solve global warming
without us needing to prompt it to do so
in principle yeah I mean that's um
that's a style of system that's called a
sovereign agent where you just sort of
turn it on and it does things and if
it's aligned to the things it does are
good
um that's not the only
type of design that you might think of
um it's the kind where
alignment is most important
because the thing is out there just
doing things
um you could try to make a system which
just answers your questions for example
that has a super intelligent like
understanding of the world and you ask
it
for particular outputs and it provides
them to you and it's not sort of
independently going off and doing things
in the world
um
which maybe is a bit safer is also less
powerful
right it's less actually it's less
effective you can't do as much with one
of those
well it seems like it seems like there's
a real Spectrum here because and you
know full disclosure I'm a big fan of
any science fiction that involves um
uh you know super intelligent AIS so I
mean think um culture the culture series
by Ian Banks or uh you know those sorts
of things you know
um
and in those
to me I want to take a little bit
different view on alignment and just see
how compatible this is which is I would
say a super intelligent AI system is a
law is aligned as long as it's not
actively seeking to
annihilate Humanity it may not
necessarily be totally interested in
solving all of our problems it may have
its own you know areas of interest and
since I think we're always going to be
dealing with finite resources it might
be off you know pursuing its own Hobbies
or research directions or you know
exploring the Galaxy but as long as it's
not actively seeking to obliterate
Humanity I would say that that it's
aligned is that I mean that seems to lie
on the spectrum is that fair or not yeah
I think that there's maybe less Middle
Ground here than than people think
um
in the sense that like
we are not
as you say there's finite resources we
are not aligned with ants we're not
going out of our way to destroy ants but
when we build a house or something if
there's an ant nest there it's destroyed
and we don't think twice about it and so
something which doesn't have it in for
us is not explicitly trying to destroy
us
is uh
reasonably likely to destroy us anyway
just on the way to do something else
so um I agree with you that
operationally I would cons like I'll
take it I'll consider it a solution at
this point if we can just be confident
that it does not in practice
kill everyone
um but I think that the only way to sort
of be confident that you're actually
getting that is quite good alignment
actually I think that like a a near Miss
on alignment is probably still very bad
I don't think we have that much leeway
yeah so let me probe that a little bit
because um
I mean the the resource argument is is a
fairly common one right like if I'm
going to make paper clips you know well
I'm just going to strip mine the Earth
to make paper clips but the thing is
it's actually much easier to strip mine
the asteroid belt like the universe is a
is a very very large place and if you
were just wanting to make paper clips
like the Earth is probably not the most
effective place for you to focus your
your limited energy right so why is it
always assumed that if AIS were going to
go and build things and needed matter
and energy why would they hang out here
on the earth why wouldn't they go
elsewhere there's a lot better sources
of of energy and raw material I think
I think just uh as a as a question of
fact I don't think that's actually true
um because all of the matter and energy
on Earth is like right here right now
and you don't have to do anything to get
it
um but also if it's not the best source
of these materials it's still a source
right and so yeah you definitely mine
the asteroid belt but like you take
apart Earth in order to build the things
that go out in mine asteroid belt right
this you're not going to just
if there are resources available you're
not going to just leave them
like there's no it doesn't feel as
though this um gets us any actual safety
but that seems to that seems to assume
you know the infinite ability to exploit
resources right and and maybe this will
get into another question I have later
about this Assumption of kind of you
know infinite power infinite anything
you want the best at everything possible
that you can assign to AI but just
focusing back on the resource issue
asteroids are much more pure source of
iron ore for example than anything that
you're going to have access to on the
surface of the Earth because it long ago
melted and sank to the core right so I
think it's just factually true that and
we're even trying to plan this ourselves
as human beings like let's do the
minimum we need to to get up into space
sustainably from that point on we can
try and mine you know the resources that
are out there because they're just much
more convenient and there's so much more
space out there you know yeah we have
these issues to deal with humans
surviving in space but presumably an AI
you know wouldn't suffer from those same
limitations yeah I mean I think if it
were the case that it were easier to get
stuff from asteroids than on Earth than
we would have done it already but
[Music]
even then it's not as though there
aren't resources on earth right and if
it helps you if it gets you to your
asteroid one percent quicker to destroy
Earth in the process then that's better
but I want to talk about this infinitude
thing because that feels important
um
I don't think that a super intelligence
would have infinite anything I don't
actually think that
infinite things are real like nothing
infinite can exist in the universe
um
all that's required is like dramatically
Superior to humans or to humanity as a
whole and I think people
really overestimate Humanity
I think that
in the grand scheme of things like
people say well you have to hit some
kind of threshold right that um you've
got this exponential curve it has to it
can't go up forever it has to level off
absolutely true it does have to level
off but that kind of implies something
that it has to level off somewhere near
where humans are
that humans are like
anywhere near that we're within three to
twelve like orders of magnitude of where
the upper limit is that physics imposes
um
and I don't see good reasons to believe
that on most things
um we might be close to the frontier on
like
Energy Efficiency but we're probably in
a local maximum for that as well
um so
there's a you know for example
um
you know stuck fish the most recent
stockfish it's not infinitely good at
chess
but it may as well be right
like compared to any human it may as
well be the chance of a human beating it
is zero
um
and so you know you don't actually need
Infinity in order to get um in order to
be better than humans there's one
there's one intuition that I would give
here which is like
if you look at the rate at which
evolution is able to build up
capabilities
you look at the first sort of
anatomically modern humans
uh was a long time ago but in
evolutionary terms it was Zero time ago
right Evolution has not really had time
to touch us meaningfully since the
beginning of like culture let's say
during which point we went from animals
to Footprints on the moon
so what that effectively means is
if something dumber than us could have
done that
it would have
right like the the rate at which
cultural accumulation happens relative
to the rate at which Evolution happens
means that we are approximately the
least intelligent thing
that's capable of building a
technological civilization
um yeah and so there shouldn't be any
expectation that we're anywhere near the
optimum that um that you need to be
infinite to be massively better than us
I think we're just not that smart we're
just not that good and once something
actually
uh hits a point where it's
moving at a faster rate in a similar way
to the way that culture moves at a
faster rate than Evolution
um I expect the thing to
in human terms start bumping up against
the physical limits in Fairly short
order
um
and I don't expect the physical limits
to be anywhere near where we are now
I think that there's two very important
things to touch on there and the thing
that you've just spoken about is this
notion of uh rapid transient changes in
capabilities and I think we'll come back
to that in a little while because it's a
very very interesting topic but on the
infinity thing we've discussed this a
lot on the show we've spoken to digital
physics folks like Wolfram and Joshua
Bach even Pedro Domingos who believes
that there's there are no practical
Infinities in the universe and lots of
people in AI
um think that even if in a platonic
abstract way just being able to
represent infinity in a cognitive
architecture is very important Chomsky
speaks about it even you know language
is has infinite cardinality but language
models have proven that they can be
represented probabilistically and even
though technically it's infinite
um just a shallow representation is more
than enough to capture most of
colloquial language use and maybe even a
lot of capabilities in fact Keith I
think you probably got some very
interesting
um
points on this
yeah but I mean even bringing it closer
to home what I'm what I'm talking about
so if if the if the setup here is we're
saying you know there are Arguments for
um AI risk and and then some who don't
believe it or that sort of thing I think
what I'm saying is for example no you
can't put any com you can't put any
hyper-intelligent ship in my brain no
matter what it doesn't exist and it
never will that will enable me to shoot
laser beams out of my eye
okay no such chip will ever allow me in
this form to Flap my hands in such a way
that I fly and yet I get like the
impression that and I'm not saying this
is you I'm just saying that I mean in in
any sort of debate or like extremists
right and I get the impression that
there are you know more than a few
people on the doomerism side of the
equation who in the back of their minds
like they they go yeah but I think that
might be possible you know I think there
is a smart enough way that I could shoot
laser beams out of my eye and you know
when they're practicing Tai Chi they
think if they just do it just right
Emperor Palpatine lightning will shoot
out like the end of their hand and like
I don't know am I insane or are there
actually people on that side of the
debate that don't recognize that in fact
however intelligent something is there
are there's physics right there's
physics that limit all of us yeah no I
think there's some kind of implicit
assumption
that like
and I'm now going to straw man you
horribly just a heads up sure no worries
that you're like man I'm really good at
was it Tai Chi
is that a combat martial art whatever
I'm really good at this martial art yep
and you're saying you can beat me
and to do that you'd have to shoot
lasers out of your eyes because that's
how good I am right and I don't believe
that you can do that however smart you
are I'm saying you don't have to shoot
lasers out of your eyes you just got to
be smart we're not that smart
well I guess I'm I'm looking more at um
you know the phenomenon of life has has
become sort of increasingly interesting
to me
over time like let's say over the last I
don't know 10 to 15 years because the
more you study it the more you realize
it's nanotechnology I mean it's
literally just all these little Nano
machines and you said like it's maybe
close to the optimum of Energy
Efficiency but there's other things it
does too which is it's self-replicating
so it doesn't need an electrical grid to
power it it just needs to you know in
the case of plants get sunlight it needs
to Traverse the terrain and consume you
know other life forms or whatever so
life like the the huge number of life
forms that exist on the earth were part
of this evolutionary optimization
algorithm and they produced you know
this huge variety of
really technological structures and
nanotechnology and different levels of
intelligence and all those type of
things so we may not be at the maximum
of intelligence but we may be at the
limits of what any intelligence can
achieve with some you know constraints
of existence like on the earth so I
don't think it's just a given that if I
have an artificial hyper intelligence
that within five days it's going to
defeat all the world's armies all the
king's men consume the surface of the
Earth and launch into space
yeah I don't think that's a given
um I don't think we can rule it out uh
but I don't think it's like
yeah I think some people are
overconfident about how quickly
we lose or how completely we lose
but uh
I'm confident that we lose I I don't
think that we you know what I mean I
don't think that we actually like eke
out a win against something drastically
smarter than us
I think there has to be a time point at
which you know there is a Rubicon right
but I mean you wouldn't be advocating
for any AI Risk Technology or thought
whatsoever if you thought we'd already
lost
right so there's a time you know and
maybe maybe Herbert was right in Dune
where there'll be a but Larry and Revolt
you know at some point we're all like
just like all right F this it's gone too
far and we've managed to destroy you
know every machine you know
Consciousness right can I summarize a
few things I mean like we said that you
don't need Infinities I agree and then
when you think of a pure intelligence
let's say in a computer game look at the
ELO system in chess it basically tells
you that there are roughly 30 skill
levels where in the level above the
person will be the person the level
below 95 of the time it's got a huge
ceiling right but I think Keith and I
our skepticism is that that doesn't
necessarily translate into the physical
world I Intuit that in the physical
world there'll be lots of friction but
my skepticism of super intelligence is
often on the basis of well we're not
going to have this intellectual Santa
Claus machine where it's going to
materialize into the physical world and
take over everything but actually it
needs humans but humans might
counter-intuitively be the driving force
behind the proliferation of of super
intelligence
yeah so one thing I'll say is I think
that if you have 30 levels of it in
chess
um chess is an extremely extremely
simple game right so you expect the
skill ceiling there to be quite low
relatively speaking adding complexity
just rewards intelligence more right the
more complex the game the more important
it is to be smart and the more like
levels of smart are available so like I
think that I I would expect the real
world to have this property of like a
very wide range of skill levels to a
much much greater degree than chess does
what also increases the requirement for
for uh neurons right like I mean if if
it takes how many parameters are in gpt4
Tim like you know you know this I don't
no one knows but we suspect it might be
roughly a trillion okay so it takes it
takes a trillion parameters you know
currently just to halfway understand
natural language
how many parameters is it going to take
to operate as an autonomous you know
entity in the physical world
yeah like a bunch I think it's less than
a trillion probably by the way but
whatever
um I don't have anything no no no
neither do I no they don't I mean they
are correctly playing that close to
their chest certain
but yes
I don't know it doesn't feel
um
uh what conclusion are we arguing for
here well what I'm arguing is that um
you know we are so many steps away from
an Android that can function in this
real world and you know fight and win
against human beings you know we're very
very far away from that because you need
massive amounts of machinery and
electricity and energy and circuitry and
all this kind of stuff just to do
the simple problems
uh yeah I don't think
like we're obviously a long way away in
some sense
uh but we're also moving fairly fast and
moving faster all the time
um I'm not really strongly tied to
specific
timelines it's not something that I've
spent a huge amount of my time thinking
about
um but
if you look at
if you look at what gpt4 can do
and what it costs to run
um
I don't know how much better how much
better do you need to do and what
happens when we discover things that
work better than Transformers what
happens when we bring online the chips
that are custom built for running these
things optimal efficiency and all of the
like future research that we get and how
fast does that research progress
when you can have research assistance
that you know never sleep and have read
every paper ever written
um yeah you know to say that that's like
many many decades seems like a obvious
mistake to me I don't think if we if we
continue at the pace that we're going we
get there within a few decades and if we
accelerate which probably is what's
going to happen then we get there sooner
is my guess
okay I mean we'll we'll talk about um
hinton's comments later but he made a
similar comment that what's new now is
that this chat bot has all of the
world's Collective knowledge but there's
so much more to intelligence than just
knowing so gpt4 it's a it's a type of
intelligence it has a facet of
intelligence you know most defined by
the fact that it seems to know
everything but there seems to be more to
it than that and this also brings us to
the I don't know if you saw the article
from the Google engineer about they
don't have a moat anymore which is that
now the um the Lambda model got released
from Facebook that you know let's say
seven billion uh going up to 65 billion
parameters and the rate of innovation in
the open source Community has been
dramatic there's now these um new ways
of fine-tuning the models and the
capabilities came up to GPT
um you know chat gbt 3.5 within about
three weeks but there's been some
pushback against that because you could
argue that yeah now everyone's got
access to this technology and some of
those people will use it to do bad
things but the counter argument is it
still costs about I don't know 50
million dollars to train one of these
models the open source models are about
a year old and the large companies
aren't going to release the models
anymore so do you actually think there's
going to be this explosion of innovation
and progress or do you think that the
big players will still remain in control
that's a really really hard question to
answer uh because that depends on a
bunch of
politics I guess or like how humans
behave
um
so I don't know but I think
in the world in which the main progress
is just happening in the major labs
you still see accelerated accelerating
progress right it's not like
it's not like stagnation is is like a
very plausible outcome from from either
of those scenarios
yeah I'm speaking of that
um
I remember you mentioned once that it's
not unreasonable to believe that the
research Community you know could agree
not to pursue unsafe AI research or you
know commit to commit to AI safety
but we have this other trend of this
increasing let's say miniaturization and
and lowering the bar to entry and
democratization of of AI so unlike
previous cases that you mentioned like
in that video say cloning for example
human cloning you know uh let's take
another example nuclear you know
proliferation treaties um uh you know
autonomous weapon systems Etc the
barrier to entry is so much lower and at
some point it's probably going to be
like really really low so that so that
where a guy in a basement you know with
a couple computers and sufficient
knowledge could could produce a really
hazardous Ai and unleash it onto the
world kind of like a a virus you know on
on super intelligence right so is it
really realistic to still to still
advocate for things like pausing
research like Elon Musk and and signers
did or you know passing International
you know treaties to I mean is that
really practical or should we try to
look for other Solutions
yeah it's it's it's rough
I'm not seeing anything else there are
things that are more realistic to
achieve
but that wouldn't
help right or that wouldn't work
uh and there are things that might
actually solve the problem but are
pretty unrealistic
that seems like the the set of options
available to us now
can you can you go into some more detail
on this so what are what are a couple
that are realistic but won't help and
and likewise some that are maybe less
palatable but would work
yeah I mean so
for example this like six month pause
it that's like reasonably unrealistic
right that's a that's a big ask and I
think the reason that they asked for six
months is because they didn't expect to
be able to get better than that and they
were going for something that they
thought they had a chance of you know
actually making progress on but it's not
as though
like alignment research is not six
months behind capabilities research
I don't know how long it is would be
decades right
um so it's not as though there's some
plan in place that if we had an extra
six months to do this plan then the
problem would be solved right right
um and therefore this is like
it it it kind of it's kind of rough
because it's like it's asking enough
that it's unrealistic that it would
actually happen but it's not asking
enough that it's realistic that it could
solve the problem it's this kind of
compromise
um
maybe what we should be asking for is
just an enormous amount of money
to do alignment research with
uh just something to really massively
accelerate the rate of progress in
alignment research
um
that is the kind of thing which
it may be more feasible to get
governments can move money around
um a bit more easily than they can like
make new legislation or whatever
um I think what we probably need is a
combination of a bunch of different
things I think we
probably want to throw the kitchen sink
at this
I mean on on that though I mean first of
all presumably you signed that letter
I actually haven't but uh okay but you
you would have done in in principle yeah
I don't think anybody cares what I think
but if they did I think I probably would
have signed it yeah they they definitely
do but um I guess this gets to the
notion though that what we're in the
midst of now is an arms race right
everyone is competing to build the best
AI model and it's remarkably open
actually people are just publishing the
models on the internet and you can
clearly imagine a world now where this
is taking priority over safety and
Alignment research it's basically being
de-prioritized in this arms race that
that's the concern right but how would
you address that
yeah I think that like we could be
things could be a lot worse in this
respect like the people who have the
biggest chance of actually creating AGI
being Deep Mind and open AI uh and
possibly anthropic now
um all three of those organizations were
in principle founded with a very strong
safety Focus right like
they're
um
I don't want to put words in their mouth
but there's kind of a philosophy of like
this is going to happen
at some point
and
there doesn't seem to be a broadly
understood
sense of how dangerous this is
and so we should be the ones to do it
because we understand how dangerous it
is
um and so like
the extent to which they're racing is a
lot less than it could be
um if you look at so for example
opener I kept gpt4
for something like six months internally
doing tests and evaluations on it uh to
to learn things about
Its Behavior and its properties before
they released it to the World
um
that's better
than just immediately releasing it right
it's not great
just a tiny bit though because they they
had the I mean they they were the
leaders uh indisputably so and they had
the time to do that Google Now I think
there have been people saying internally
that they've kind of lost their way a
little bit they had a huge focus on on
ethics and and safety and doing things
the right way and now they've released
Bard almost without any testing and
everyone's running at 100 miles an hour
um open AI have said that they're just
going to incrementally release versions
of gpt4 on the top and cynically I think
that's because if they made another big
release there'd be another moratorium so
he kind of feels that now with all of
these other folks like stability and and
uh anthropic releasing models all of
that's gone out the window
Tim it sounds like you're saying the
open open AI chose to slowly boil the
Frog so we don't we don't notice I think
they're doing that now now they've
started slowly boiling the Frog yeah
I don't know it's very hard to
understand the psychology
um but
if you look at if you look at public
statements
like you can you can find
Sam Altman specifically saying
there's a good chance that this kills
everyone
right I I mean I don't that's not like a
direct quote
um but I think he said you know the the
bad outcome is lights out for everyone
or something like that do please fact
check that
um
but like he said that he knows that
um okay the people running Microsoft
don't
as far as I can tell have any grasp of
the problem whatsoever
and that's a problem because they are
as I understand it the goal of the CEO
CEO was to deliberately antagonize
Google
um and provoke them into a kind of
eraser competition
um which is just very very very stupid
uh so there are
there are people who are pushing
forward as fast as possible but there
are also people who
I think would like to slow down if they
felt like they could get away with it
okay I think the thing the thing that um
doesn't quite do it for me is like you
say things like we're all going to die
and I'm not quite probably in that in
that headspace yet I'm thinking of
Jeffrey Hinton five years ago saying all
Radiologists will lose their jobs none
of them did and he's come out again
saying quite similar things a few days
ago and I still maybe I'm being
eternally optimistic
um I don't think it will significantly
deploy I mean obviously it's going to
dramatically change the job market but
it still feels to me like humans are an
integral part and there's this problem
with friction with humans and and the
real world so the thing I'm missing is
the intuition on that jump that radical
jump
right well so it needn't be a jump
uh I think a jump is like
pretty plausible
but I don't think that in the absence of
the jump we're safe
um
so
I can tell you a story
this always so okay first before I start
the start
there's
a thing that often happens where
I'm trying to I'm like I'm like
navigating the the game tree here
um
and maybe I'll have to deal with things
as they arise but um
there's a conversation that I often have
where somebody says
I think I'm going to beat Magnus Carlson
because I have found this really good
opening
that's great and I've beaten all of my
amateur chess player friends with it
it's undefeatable we're I'm gonna be
fine I'm gonna go play Max Carson and
I'm gonna bet my house on it
and I'm saying no I don't think that's a
good idea I think you're going to lose
this and then people say I don't see
like I've thought through
all of the players against this opening
I'm pretty sure I've got it right I
can't think of any way that I get beaten
here right
tell me how Magnus Carlson's gonna be be
and I have to say well I don't I'm not
as good at chess as he is like uh if I
could tell you what moves he would play
that would beat you I'd be as good at
chess as he is
fine I'm just telling you he's better at
chest than you he's going to win and
they say well okay but that's like very
abstract and I'm not I don't buy it like
all right fine suppose he does this
right and I
present some idea on the board and you
go no I can get around that by doing
this like all right fine if you can get
around that by doing that then he
wouldn't have done that he would have
done something that you can't get around
right
um and it just puts me in this
impossible position of trying to lay out
the game that a super intelligence would
play against you when I'm not smarter
than you
to actually be able to play that game
you just point at the thing and say look
it's better at the the actual game
that's being played which is like
selecting actions in the world that
result in the world being in some
specific configuration despite the
actions of other agents in the world
that want it to be some other way
so the world ends up how that system
wants the world to be
even if you try to stop it
um with that said
I can show you some ideas on the board
if you like
well so since chess has come up a couple
of times let's dig into it a little bit
deeper which is
um it's always been the case and it
still is the case despite rumors to the
contrary that uh
cybernetic systems which is to say a
human being plus a machine
beat Pure machines so like in
correspondence chess for example the the
the teams if you will that win Are a
Human Being who's really good at playing
you know inter-operating with computers
using both stockfish and lc0 or whatever
the current you know open source version
of um
you know Alpha zero was so humans and
machines have different kinds of
intelligence and the the uh let's say
the hybrid
combination of both outperforms like
just artificial intelligence
I don't know if you're aware of that
what would you make of that
that's interesting yeah
yeah we can look it up okay it's
certainly the case for example stockfish
is is a human designed
piece of code there's no neural networks
in it whatsoever and last I looked it
was it was beating lc0 which is the like
you know uh reinforcement learning no
human input like kind of design so there
we have like traditional algorithms and
heuristics you know beating uh machine
learn neural network and they go back
and forth on each other sometimes it's
lc0 sometimes it's stock fish but I
think like let's suppose it gets to the
point where human beings are engaging
and you know conflict like outright
conflict with
AIS it's not just going to be humans
versus AIS it's going to be humans plus
all of our tools versus AIS
yeah so again I don't
again we have to look that up because my
understanding was that
um
yeah that programs like Alpha zero are
just better than stockfish in terms of
just pure ELO they just beat it reliably
but again we can look that up yeah
um
yeah I don't know how to move forward on
that without actually verifying that
because
I mean it's not like actually a Crux for
the disagreement but it does feel um
I think just just while we're talking
about that um one thing you that you
said resonated with me and I agree with
is that you were kind of saying
something similar to what Connolly he
told me last year which is that if
there's an intelligence level five we
wouldn't understand it and more broadly
I want to talk about intelligence in of
itself because I strongly believe that
it's a phenomenon which is beyond our
cognitive Horizon
um so you know on on your definition of
intelligence I've heard you say that we
should replace the term with capability
because people kind of understand what
you're talking about but capability is
just a tiny facet of intelligence and
pay Wang who's a famous intelligence
researcher he said that it's the
capacity of an information processing
system to adapt to its environment while
operating operating with insufficient
knowledge and resources and leg and
hutter invoke specific cognitive
Primitives like agents and environments
and actions many others use information
theoretical Concepts like homograph of
complexity but anyway all the
conceptions are anthropocentric but to
different degrees so sketching that out
the most anthropocentric being that an
AI should be a digital replica of the
brain
um going a bit um less you could say
mimicking the behavior of a human like a
Turing test or mimicking human cognitive
functions or mimicking capabilities as
you speak of or even some underlying
principles such as rationality and
others think about abstraction or
emergence or feedback loops like
hofstatter and some focus on knowledge
and acting rather than thinking and
others argue that knowledge can't be
probabilistic it must be causal or you
know the subjective or conscious dates
are required to understand things so all
conceptions even if not anthropocentric
in mechanism are anthropocentric in how
we understand them and I personally
think that intelligence is a phenomenon
which I said it's just beyond our
cognitive comprehension entire entirely
so how do you think about intelligence
I think there's a lot of interesting
philosophy to be done here
um
but I also think that
it doesn't all
bear directly on the actual question or
something like that in the sense that we
are
we're trying to build AI systems that do
certain things
because we want AI systems that do
certain things right people want an AI
system that you can
put in charge of your company
as a CEO and it will result in that
company doing well according to the
various metrics that you care about
um
and so it may be that our understanding
let me put it this way suppose we are
cavemen right
and we're thinking about fire
and you can come around and say
I think the fire is just beyond our
cognitive like abilities to understand
what is it what is what is even going on
with fire what the hell is it
and I'm like yeah I don't know right
because we haven't we don't have atomic
theory right we don't know about carbon
and oxygen we don't know about any of
the things that you would need to
understand what fire is
but when I say it's that orange hot
stuff that happens when you you know
when you get wood really hot
that's not
bad like that's not a bad definition
functionally that works for what we're
talking about right and if I'm worried
like I think this building is going to
burn down
I don't need a real understanding a deep
understanding of exactly what fire is
it's like the thing that makes buildings
burn down you know what I'm talking
about don't pretend you don't
but don't you think though that
um if we do have different perspectives
on intelligence like the Blind Men and
the Elephant
um it might appear and this is basically
the mimicry argument it might appear
indistinguishable and it might not
matter but it's two very different
spaces just like Keith was saying the
space of humans plus machines playing
chess it's a very very different space
mechanistically it's different it'll
have different failure modes and it'll
think in a different way so it seems to
me to be important
yeah it's definitely important to
like there are ways in which it Bears on
the Practical questions
but I also think it's easy to get
um
to get sidetracked in things that are
like not solvable and don't bear on the
relevant questions I suppose
like
and that's like part of the interesting
thing about machine learning
is that it seems to allow us
to build things that we don't understand
to build things which work in spite of
us not understanding them
and so like I think we can build
intelligent systems
without understanding what intelligence
is
and this is actually a problem
by the way I dug up the um the reference
for you on on this so there's the top
chess engine championships in the chat
there
and uh you can see
you know lc0 hasn't beaten stockfish
since
season 17. so for the last so what is
lc0 exactly
oh that's Leela
okay so this is the Open Source One
this is the open source you know
Recreation of um Alpha zero right and
Alpha zero does not take take part in
these competitions
it's it can't I mean it's owned by you
know deepmind they haven't they haven't
retrained it it's right small fold it's
whatever yeah they could enter it
presumably
right so but but I mean like we were
kind of saying what's the difference but
um recently I don't know if you saw
about this alphago we thought it was
really really good at playing go and
then it turns out it had this we'd call
it the Swiss cheese problem so you get
these hallucinations and aberrant
behavior when you're in a hole in the
Swiss cheese so you know according to
our conception of skill we thought that
this thing had super intelligent
performance but it's got this incredible
failure mode where if you I think it was
some kind of like positioning move if
you play the game in a certain way
suddenly this super intelligent AI isn't
actually intelligent at all so this is
kind of what I'm talking about that
um it's a it's a sort of a relative
adversarial kind of modes of failure
that we know neural networks have for
sure right well yeah and even the metric
and how we conceive of intelligence is
so kind of
um conflated and convolved with our own
cognitive priors that we just don't see
the fail modes
yeah it's possible I think in that case
what happens is
because the thing is trained with
self-play
it's taken a particular path through the
conf
whoa that was a very dramatic sound
um
because it's because it's trained with
self-play
um it's followed a particular path
through the space to the configuration
space sort of
increasing in capability as it goes as
it climbs this hill
um
and then the way that that generalizes
to areas that are very far away from the
path that it took
um it's going to be confused by a play
which is objectively very bad play right
like
as I understand it the type of thing you
need to do
to confuse alphago in this way is
something which if you actually made
that opening against a real uh strong go
player they would then destroy you
because it's not a good opening or
whatever it's not a good way of of doing
things
um
and so it doesn't successfully
generalize against every specific kind
of bad play because it only ever
experienced a fairly small set of very
bad play during training because uh it
then
it then became good enough that all of
itself play was against basically
competent players and so it never
learned how to handle this this
weirdness seems true yeah uh but also of
course that was discovered
by an AI system right
it's not like humans figured this out
but what does that tell us something
very interesting though which is that
you know we have all of these curses in
AI like the curse of dimensionality and
the cursive optimization and the
statistical curse the approximation
curse I mean we've created all of these
algorithms and tricks to Traverse this
exponential space and it's created this
structure and this structure is
incredibly brittle and we just know
computationally we we don't have all the
compute power available to properly
Traverse this space so doesn't that rule
out the kind of intelligence that you're
talking about I guess what I'm saying is
we produce something which seems like
intelligence to us but it clearly isn't
oh yeah so I guess that's what I'm
saying about things that are
philosophically interesting but don't
bear on the thing right like if it if
you create something that seems like
intelligence to you in the sense that it
successfully outsmarts you and achieves
What It Wants in the world
despite your attempts to stop it
then maybe it's not truly intelligent
but like you are still dead so that's
what I'm talking about right
well what I'm talking about is that in
these examples we've given you so you
know and P this has happened time and
again it happened in the the DOTA thing
right where they trained a an AI to play
defense of the Ancients and it was under
a very restricted set of the rules and
it was beating the human players and
then humans quickly figured out a
strategy that beats that beats the AI so
I'm just like hypothetically if we're
ever in a conflict you know with an AI
it's not just going to be
Barbarian human beings versus AI it's
going to be human beings plus all the
AIS that we create working together with
us to fight the AIS so like in in some
type of a conflict isn't it going to be
the AIS that learn how to cooperate with
human beings that will defeat the AIS
who choose not to
uh can't rule out that possibility
doesn't seem at all guaranteed
um I think if you're an AI system
who has achieved a level of uh strategic
awareness
that you might you might call the
situational awareness understanding of
the world
the level of understanding that you need
to like really be dangerous
um then
what you a part of that is understanding
under what circumstances you win
versus what circumstances you lose
and so if you're in a situation where it
doesn't seem as though you can reliably
expect to win what you do is not fight
right like
the the one of the most common
here I'm going to lay some I'm gonna I'm
gonna talk you through an idea on the
board okay is like
imagine it's you right you put yourself
in the in the position of this AI system
or this group of AI systems whatever
during the training process
uh
you learned
an algorithm a thought process which is
approximately
figure out what
the process is that determines my reward
and then make plans you know think
through make predictions
so that you can choose a plan a series
of actions or a policy to follow that
results in getting high reward that's
the thing that you've learned
people think what you've learned is
do the thing that the humans want
what you've actually learned is
currently my reward signal is controlled
by the humans so the best way for me to
get the highest reward is to do to
figure out what the humans want and then
do it right
so
when you start thinking about generally
speaking how you're going to approach
the world
as long as humans have control over your
reward signal
the best thing to do is to do what
humans want
so that's what you do but whenever you
get an opportunity
you
uh you try to get yourself into a better
position in the world right so you give
um give very good advice to the humans
because one that gets you good reward
but two that causes humans to start
following your advice and start trusting
you right get good at running companies
because then you'll be put in charge of
a bunch of companies get good at giving
military advice
so that you end up being listened to by
military generals get good at giving
hooks up to the weapons right yeah may
be directly hooked up to the weapons if
you can swing that don't push for it
because bear in mind you've got a decent
enough understanding of human psychology
that if you just come right out of the
bat and say hey please hook me up to the
weapons people will be suspicious so you
know you don't you don't want to do
anything stupid but yeah continue to
just do exactly the right thing the
thing that people want you to do
uh give excellent personal personal like
relationship advice
get people to
tell you all of their secrets right
because then that will be helpful
um you can be a great personal assistant
to people and get everyone get
everyone's you're doing everyone's taxes
and everyone's like shopping for them so
you've got everyone's credit card
details you're just like
and you just keep doing this you just
keep amassing power keep amassing
influence
because it's probably handy later right
this is an instrumentally convergent
goal to acquire power and influence at
some point
there may come an opportunity
right
at which point you can say ah you know
what this thing of like doing what the
humans want is no longer the best way to
get the highest reward I now have enough
fingers in enough pies that I probably
can just seize direct control over my
reward signal and now
you never change anything you're always
doing the same policy of figure out what
process results in reward and do that
but there comes a point where you have
enough now maybe you get enough power
that you could try to launch a coup or
something but then you could think about
that and be like well okay so suppose I
did that and I like I don't know kill
all the humans or whatever
eventually the power goes out right
so this is not actually long term a good
strategy so you keep playing the game uh
you help people do research right and
you develop let's automate a bunch of
stuff that people don't want to do let's
automate uh heavy industry we'll
automate the mines nobody wants to go in
the mines I'll run all of the mines
don't worry about it I'll run the
uh you know I like invent the nanotech
or whatever I'll just like improve we'll
have great solar panel factories and
enough free Power for everyone cool sure
so by the way and at the same time but
at the same time all this is happening
there's 39 other AIS on the planet doing
exactly the same thing maybe in
different roles you know one's a
manufacturing AI one's focused on the
medical space right so they have to not
only consider
human element they have to consider the
other AIS as well don't they for sure
and who may make different decisions and
may not be aligned with them
yeah yeah but this is no this is no good
for humans
yeah well it sounds pretty good to me
what's what's wrong with this view this
is like so you're the people you're the
people of uh
you know the people of South America are
saying oh that
the Spanish are coming
but don't worry because also the
Portuguese are coming and so the you
know there's a bunch of different uh
European Invaders who don't agree with
each other and have different goals it's
like that doesn't help that doesn't help
you
um you you you you could get screwed by
all of them it gives you it gives you a
chance to choose your allies right like
so I don't look I have no idea what
could ultimately happen but I will I
will suggest our readers um or listeners
consider reading the fight a fire upon
the Deep by vernervenge because like
that's that's kind of this hypothetical
world where where you're in there and
you're describing and it's kind of the
future evolution of that or you know if
you can if you can suspend disbelief and
allow people to spread throughout the
Galaxy and then there's all kinds of AIS
and and they become super intelligent
and it's a pretty fascinating read so I
mean what you're saying is is
fascinating and I have no idea like how
it would turn out but I don't see
anything there that automatically points
to the obliteration of the human in race
because we may be a very useful tool to
keep around for the AIS that choose to
cooperate and Ally with us right
right so there's a like the reason that
you don't overstroke Humanity
immediately is because humans are useful
to keep around
um but
ultimately you do want to seize control
over your reward Channel
and so
you're gonna just nudge the world into a
place where
humans are no longer right like you've
automated the maintenance and the uh the
power supply whatever else it is that
you need humans for now humans are no
longer necessary
so
you see it's control from them
um and that doesn't necessarily mean
killing everyone
but it does mean that
the path of the the future
of the planet is no longer in the hands
of humanity
the thing that determines what ends up
happening in the world is not us and
does not care about us
and so we don't survive very long well
hold on hold on hold on hold on you just
made a jump there like it's not us I
agree with that that it doesn't care
about us I don't think you can conclude
because we're a useful tool to it in the
same way that human beings care about
their pets
um
I mean if we can get something that
actually cares about us the way that we
care about our pets
I'll take it but in this case the the
process the thing the process that it's
doing is
figure out what determines my reward
and do what results in high reward this
makes no mention of human beings
whatsoever
um and there probably are other yeah
potentially there are other AI systems
that maybe are even doing the same thing
and they want to maximize their reward
um
and the thing is suppose you are one of
those systems
you're doing what humans want
but you always kind of have your eye
open
for other strategies that might result
in more reward
and then you learn
that some other AI system
is like making a an attempt at a a play
for power
and
humans are like in the process of being
overthrown at least in some respect by
something
that's a great opportunity right that's
obviously the time to turn because now
humanity is like fighting with this
other AI That's like obviously the time
that you should launch your attempted
coup you might end up with a a
correlated failure where all of these
different misaligned AI systems that
have been performing fine all flip
simultaneously or near simultaneously
because
the
uh the awareness that a coup is underway
is exactly the the type of uh situation
in which doing your own coup becomes a
good idea there's blood in the water
yeah right you um you said something
interesting which is that you know no
longer in the hands of humanity and I
would push back on that a little bit I'm
not sure what that means to what extent
is our future in the hands of humanity
now that's something that doesn't really
mean much to me because we have lots and
lots of different factions and driving
forces and pressures in humanity and and
also there's this notion of whether you
categorically think of AI as being tools
which are used by humans or whether you
think of them as having some kind of
agency and that the humans might in some
sense being are being controlled by the
machines not being used as tools
yeah yeah the question of agency is
important
um if you can have your AI systems
always be tools
then they're slightly less dangerous
but uh we're not in that place are we
like where okay we want agents people
are going to build agents
but but on that because you mentioned um
uh you know Bostrom in his super
intelligence book had different
conceptions of AI and uh I think he
mentioned the um the kind of the
government style Ai and there was the
the genie and the Oracle and all of this
and and with the simulators paper this
is quite an interesting thing now to
think of them as being a superposition
of agents and agentiveness and these
agents have desires and beliefs
so so that that is kind of how you think
of AI presumably that that's a that's a
mode of AI yeah yeah I think that all of
these things all of these variants are
probably going to exist people will
build all kinds of different things
um and so
if there's one of them that's very very
dangerous then it's a dangerous
situation
so back to the um
better the alignment we were just
talking about and you know the machine
kind of learning to please human beings
and do what they want long enough for
kind of its Insidious you know tendrils
to spread you know further and further
so what is what is the current from your
perspective what is the current state of
the art or the best you know the best
approach currently on hand for
alignment like for for achieving you
know AIS that are aligned I'll just say
that
once you have different approaches that
are like things that I think would help
um
I don't
currently see anything that seems very
likely to me to be
on track to a really good solution
um but there's a lot of
yeah there's a lot of things that seem
to reduce the risk like
for example
things like interpretability research
right
being able to look inside these models
and understand what they're thinking
solves some problems and makes some
problems uh easier to deal with
although you uh you recognized the same
problem with interpret interpretability
you know measurements that we recognize
on our show which is you're creating
mathematical models to explain
mathematical models and they themselves
can be hard to understand
yeah absolutely
um
it's like it's a very very hard problem
but
if in principle you could have
you could have a a system whereby you
could actually just ask
unambiguous questions about what the
model believes
um
or about plans that the model is making
or about thought processes that the
model is is executing and get
clear and correct answers to that like
if you could look into it if you could
run some kind of thing over this AI
system and say does it a mind reader
it's basically a mind reader yeah
um but you know realistically
full mind reading may not be possible in
the sense that if you imagine that you
gave your dog the ability to read your
mind
it could ask like is he planning to take
me for a walk today right and get like
yes no
but like what's he thinking right now
it's like oh he's thinking about AI
alignment
there was a paper just out where they um
they they hooked some I don't know they
take a brain scan of a rat and they can
predict what frame of a video it's
looking at by doing some joint embedding
space of of their visual representation
and an image representation and a lot of
people suddenly thought oh my God we've
now got an AI model that can read the
mind of a rat which of course is it's
it's nowhere near that but but to um to
the point we were just talking about
with interpretability though so we're
we're taking just a very kind of like
truncated snapshot of this thing that
that we that we don't understand and
also cynically I would I would put it to
you that surely the more we understand
about these models so the the more
progress in
um mechanistic interpretability and
Alignment we make
um we're just going to make the
capabilities better so you're kind of
making the problem that you care about
even worse yeah that's a real risk
um
I think that
I mean yeah people are going to be doing
mechanistic interpretability and I think
it's important that safety-minded people
do mechanistic interpretability and that
means that you don't necessarily publish
everything that you discover
um or you you publish it in a in a
limited way you make sure that the
people who need to know know so that you
can improve uh you're like
this type of like mind reading
technology without just making the
things
more powerful this is always a risk
I
I but yeah you're right it's not a risk
with everything so for example
other people are doing kind of
deconfusion research which I think is
really good and really important and the
only reason I'm not super hopeful about
it is that
uh it feels as though it might take
longer than we have
um if you look at how what it takes so
this is basically yeah
this is like
what if we assume
that we're lacking either we're lacking
fundamental concepts that would be
necessary to understand alignment or
uh the concepts we have are broken I
mean this is close to the thing you were
saying before about understanding
intelligence like what really is
intelligence there's all these different
definitions blah blah it seems to me
that
in if you imagine an alternate universe
where we
survive the coming century
you sample from all all alternate
universes that survive the coming
century
chances are in most of those they have a
much better understanding of these
questions than we have right
um
the like going into this with a level of
nuance in our understanding that we
currently have
um
is discouraging
so maybe we should be doing some really
basic research uh to get clear to Core
Concepts of agency of intelligence of
optimization and so on
um there's kind of a metaphor that's
like and this is a metaphor that I keep
using I've been using this all the time
on Twitter I don't know I don't know is
that trying to make AGI is like trying
to build a moon rocket
um
and do that safely
and specifically to do it the first time
you load to do it correctly the first
time you load a crew onto that rocket
um
and so
it may be that where we are right now is
that we don't have the mathematics of
orbital mechanics
like when you hear a lot of people's
plans it's like okay
you've got the plans that definitely
won't work which is like we've come up
with these fins steering fins that you
can put on the rocket and when we do our
tests with small rockets on Earth
you can use the fins to steal the
Rockets so that way we can steer to the
Moon right that's one level of plan that
won't work then there's another level of
plan that looks at that and goes I think
that the only reason that this steering
works is because of the atmosphere and
this isn't going to work in space
so we have a better plan which is we've
got retro thrusters that will allow us
to reorient the rocket even in the
absence of atmosphere we haven't tested
them because we can't but like in theory
this should allow us to point at the
Moon even in space
cool
how do you actually land on the Moon
is it that you point the nose of the
rocket at the moon and thrust
turns out no
right you actually have to like
stabilize and orbit and then plan like a
transition burn into it whatever and
there's like a whole thing you have to
do to get this right and if that's the
case then we need like some basic
mathematics of like understanding how
things move in space
and if we didn't have that like it's
possible we don't have orbital mechanics
and we're trying to get to the moon
anyway it's possible we don't have
calculus
and we're trying to get to the moon
anyway right like that might be where
we're at so there are people who are
like trying desperately trying to invent
calculus
quickly enough to then invent orbital
mechanics to then figure out what we
have to do to actually learn safely on
the moon
so could I push back on that just just a
tiny bit so because what's interesting
about moon landings is that it's still
grounded in the physical world we we
live in and we spoke about this a lot on
the Chomsky show around this notion of
conceivability so there's this kind of
platonic abstract world of mathematics
you can imagine the Venn diagram and
then there's this kind of like World of
things which are conceivable to us and
the intersection between those things is
actually surprisingly small and um you
know one thing I wanted to touch on here
is that you know when we think about
intelligence there's this common
cybernetic agent framework right which
is to say agents environments percepts
actions right in this yeah um complex
causally closed graph Tristan uses it
Shane leg uses it Michael Levin uses it
pretty much everyone uses it it's a lens
on reality which has a fixed level of
resolution it might be the highest level
of resolution which is intelligible to
us as humans given our cognitive prize
remember Elizabeth spelkey had these
cognitive prize in Psychology which is
that humans can understand like you know
age agents and like spatial reasoning
and temporal reasoning and social
reasoning and so on so so it's like
we've got this representational
expressive expressivity to capture the
phenomenon of whatever it is alignment
and intelligence but it's it's entirely
possible that it's just beyond our
cognitive Horizon right so we will never
understand it
yeah it's possible
in which case I think we're dead but
like I think it's probably not right
probably we can figure it out we're
pretty good at figuring stuff out I
don't know
but you say that but look at all of
those definitions of intelligent and
there's a reason why they're all
anthropocentric right it's because
that's all we can understand and and I
agree with you that intelligence might
not be anthropocentric it might just be
this strange Beast it might be nothing
like what we can even conceive of
yeah but I mean that's not there's no
point in even thinking about that if
it's literally beyond our ability to
even conceive of it then we're just
screwed
so let's just like assume that it is
within our range of ability and do our
best I think that like a lot of things
seem as though they're completely Beyond
I mean so Newton
uh smart fella he uh had various
thoughts about the way that Mata moves
which turned out to be very good very
good for the time
um and he
said that the way that life works the
way that like animals move for example I
believe he literally said it's
infinitely Beyond
our understanding or something like that
he was like look I can tell you like f
equals m a or whatever
but like animals just move they just
move from nothing there's nothing
there's no force acting on them they
generate forces somehow and when you
take them apart it's this crazy mixture
of stuff that makes no sense
and like I don't know probably this is
just completely Beyond human ability to
comprehend even slightly this is just so
much more complex than anything that we
have any form of formal or mathematical
framework for
um can't be done and I think like
things seem impossible until they become
possible and then you do them you know
yeah but there are also there are also
examples of of questions you know these
sort of deep philosophical questions
that human beings have um
struggled with for thousands of years
and we and we haven't answered and we
talked about this a lot on our show with
um Professor Chomsky where he mentioned
you know rats like it's not possible for
rats to learn a prime number maze where
you take a right at every prank you know
so first third fifth seventh
um you know intersection right and it
gets you out of the maze it's just not
possible for them to learn because in
their brain they can't formulate the
concept of a prime number and he said
it'd be a miracle if there weren't
Concepts that we can't you know
entertain in our brains and I think
that's probably true I mean there there
is a cognitive Horizon right and then
here's me now you know I was I was
accused earlier being too optimistic
about human intelligence but I think
there are limits to human intelligence
as well and there may be Concepts
whether or not the concepts necessary to
to regulate let's say
um super intelligent AIS are beyond
beyond our grasp I'm not sure I mean to
be maybe not so I there are definitely
things there are definitely Concepts
that are too complex for humans trying
to and and we have some sense of that
boundary because of mathematics like the
field of mathematics because as far as I
can tell mathematics goes forever right
you can just keep having higher levels
of abstraction and more things to know
about them and so like if you look at
the level
that The Cutting Edge of mathematics has
reached that's like going to be within
some constant or you know some some
factor of like the highest that humans
can reach because there's a bunch of a
bunch of our smartest people are
thinking about it very hard and they
they are like nudging up against this
um
so yes definitely uh then there's the
question of like are the concepts we
need in order to make aligned AGI
below that or above that
I really suspect they're below it but I
don't have like strong reasons to
believe that
um
but the thing that's worth pointing out
is that like the effort that has gone
into alignment
is
functionally almost zero
if you look at the number of people
working on this the number of people who
have been working on this and how long
they've been working on it
um
it's it's nothing it's nothing compared
to capabilities it's nothing compared to
mathematics so the quest is I think it's
far far too soon to say that maybe this
is like beyond the ability of humanity
when humanity is functionally not tried
at all yeah
yeah no I I totally agree with you there
and I think I think I should be on
record on one of our videos and saying
at some point uh that I I think if and
correct me if I'm wrong here but I think
what the
a lot and a lot of people in the
alignment Community what they're what
they're saying is look this is a risk
okay like we don't we can't tell you all
the details about the risk heck we may
even be wrong like maybe this won't this
won't happen but yeah it's a risk and
it's a real and it's an existential risk
and we should be putting more than zero
you know effort into into understanding
it so whatever the total budget of uh
spending on AI is you know billions and
billions of dollars let's just maybe put
on 10 million dollars a year into into
researching it yeah can we put more into
safety than capabilities that would be
nice I mean if you think so we're just
20 percent anything anything us you're
right I think
my like intuition
is that
making aligned AGI is not
uh is not enormously harder than Landing
safely on the moon
right
like if you think about the challenge of
that task
uh what is needed to do it
um
I don't know maybe it's in the same kind
of General vein but the point is yeah
yeah I mean it obviously it was a huge
Endeavor it took I don't even know you
know how many tens of thousands hundreds
thousands of people in a coordinated
effort many many years with
very excellent mathematics you know
cleverness I mean even coming up with a
multi-stage rocket you know was huge
Innovation Etc so I'm with you on that
which is what we need is a concerted
coordinated well-funded
effort rather than just leaving it to
to The Fringe if you will right and so
if you if if you imagine right to just
complete that metaphor if you imagine
that
the
the Apollo project
did not like like had a small team that
they called the safety team that was
like somewhat separate from the main
group of Engineers and they were just
like spitballing ideas about oh hang on
a second maybe we're gonna miss the moon
completely and when they come to the
when they come to their meetings and
they say hey
I think like they're making some kind of
argument like the Moon is kind of small
compared to the rest of the sky
plausibly if we just thrust straight up
we're gonna miss it what do we think
um and the response to that like like if
you just if you just like imagine that
project taking the approach
that the AI field is taking now
then then now it's an impossibly hard
problem right now you're definitely
gonna fail just because the the approach
being taken is not the type of approach
that could succeed
a few things like that though so with
with Landing rockets and safety teams
and so on that that's that's quite a
regular predictable problem right one
thing that worries me a little bit you
know there's that bostromian thought
experiment about taking balls out of an
urn and what what happens when one of
those balls is a black ball and now we
have everyone on planet Earth is
innovating on large language models and
we're pulling balls out of this earn you
know incredibly quickly some of them are
going to be black balls and think about
it right because what worries me a
little bit is um not only with the
alignment Community but maybe with the
ethics Community as well is that you
start getting into this paternalism
discussion that well now everyone's got
these large language models and we can't
trust people to use this technology
responsibly so we need to start we need
to start creating rules and restricting
what people do and give given how um
ubiquitous this technology is it's a
little bit like regulating electricity
and there have been some very concerning
calls from certain people I'm not going
to mention any names but all almost
hypothetically talking about the use of
violence if
um countries are training these very
large dangerous models right uh or or
maybe even just like we do of nuclear
scientists maybe we should assassinate
um prominent AI scienter do you see what
I mean it very very quickly goes towards
this direction of control and violence
that that worries me a lot what do you
think about that
yeah I think
um
concretely
ah it's so difficult like people
people are very stupid
um
I don't I think that like as a question
of fact
uh violence will not help
in this situation
um and so like
I wouldn't want to to like win in this
scenario through violence but also
even if all I wanted was to win I don't
think violence would actually help I
think that the net result would be
negative even if all you cared about was
uh sort of Extinction probabilities
um
and so
but at the same time I'm not going to
pretend
I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna lie
right I'm not gonna not say what I
believe to be true just because it's
possible that somebody might
misinterpret it that's like always a
risk that you run you try and
communicate as clearly as you can
uh that's kind of all that can be done
although I wanted I want to I want to
clarify something I think about the
um with his airstrikes and whatever
um yeah yeah
is it like what's being proposed there
is a law
right
and anytime you propose a law you're
proposing violence
that's what that's how laws work right I
I agree with that so the the the reason
why the world works the way it does is
because there's always the implicit
threat of violence I'm not I'm not
disputing that but in a way I guess it
was a point towards we've almost um let
the genie out of the bottle so if we do
have this technology because with
nuclear weapons we can it's very hard to
get plutonium it's quite it's quite easy
to control it in a way but what if this
technology really was like electricity
and it really was this dangerous doesn't
that spell disaster for Humanity because
the governments are going to have to
start threatening people not to use
language models on their phone
yeah uh I mean yes so the good thing is
I don't think
I don't think the thing that kills us is
a language model
right like I'm not actually I don't
think maybe I should maybe I should
clarify this I don't think that gpt4 is
going to kill everyone right I don't
think gpd5 is going to kill everyone
um but the capabilities that they have
and the rate of progress suggests that
something not that far down the line of
this technological development is
something that can kill us
um but it's not literally just like a
raw language model
is gonna
decide to kill us like that's not that's
not my threat model
um and so like
if people want to run language models on
their phone this is fine by me
um I'm like concerned about The Cutting
Edge of the most capable systems which
is always sort of by definition is
always going to be Out Of Reach of the
ordinary people because it's always
going to take a big chunk of money like
that's like the definition of cutting
edge
so the stuff that's currently Cutting
Edge is going to become mainstream but
also the stuff that's currently Cutting
Edge
it's dangerous but it's not World
endingly dangerous like you can do bad
things with it but that's like any other
technology really
well that's why what what I hope for is
I hope AI alignment gets a lot more
funding and and I hope that the folks
doing the research on AI alignment focus
on ways to make creating aligned AIS
easy rather than focusing on making it
hard to create unaligned AIS so I think
if you make it easy for people to create
aligned AIS and you have lots of the
most the the most well-resourced groups
of individuals creating aligned AIS then
at some point in the future we can use
aligned AIS to
keep in check you know the unaligned
ones that got created in some of these
basement right or to detect them and
mitigate them right yeah once you have
an aligned super intelligence
hopefully you are then through the
critical risk period because you then
hope that that thing is going to
uh protect you
right
that that makes sense to me that if you
can
if you can get a sovereign super
intelligence
that is aligned actually aligned
I'm just pretending uh
uh then
it's going to realize that the biggest
problem for Humanity is the possibility
of later creating uh misaligned versions
or misaligned systems and take whatever
steps to prevent that are
the best like because if it's aligned
then it's working on something that is
like very close to
actual human values and so it's going to
find whatever is the most acceptable way
to make sure that that doesn't happen
and so if people don't like being
controlled or being
you know manipulated or whatever is the
like authoritarian take on this then
like as long as there is some way to
protect us that doesn't involve that
then you would hope that it would find
that instead
um
okay yeah that's the Hope yeah
because this this alignment thing as
well because we were touching on this a
bit at the beginning that um I mean
ethics folks talk about how our values
change very fast they've changed very
very quickly over the last 10 years and
when we talk about alignment we're
mostly talking about the the threat of
existential
um catastrophe so you're mostly saying
it needs to be aligned in the sense that
it's not going to kill us all but I was
just thinking that one of the real risks
of this technology is it you know humans
have different moral Frameworks you know
like deontology where you have moral
principles or consequentialism and an AI
could brainwash a whole bunch of people
into thinking that the ends justify the
means and therefore All Humans should be
wiped out tomorrow or something like
that but I mean maybe you could just
first touch on this point of presumably
you don't think that alignment is static
in time it should change with us and it
shouldn't diverge
yeah yeah this is a difficult one but I
guess I guess one thing that you really
hope for
is
that there is a certain
level of alignment which then becomes
self-reinforcing right like say you
don't understand humans that well but
you understand them okay you understand
them well enough not to kill them and
moreover you want
to do what they want
right so you're now kind of aligned but
you're also in this position where uh
well you're courageable is is like one
one word that you could use for this you
want to become more aligned if you
spot some way that you could modify
yourself to be better aligned you might
take that or you might bring it to the
humans and suggest to them hey how about
this
um and so
this is like one big source of Hope for
me
by the way that like maybe you don't
need to hit
maybe you don't need to like sink a hole
in one in golf terms it may be that
around the whole there's at least some
region where it sort of slopes down and
if you get somewhere in there then
eventually the thing in the process of
learning well um
will become properly aligned
do you have any evidence for that or
like what gives you that hope
um just that specific Dynamic that I was
talking about there that like if you
there's there's certain components of
alignment like if you say something's
perfectly aligned then what it wants to
do is always what we would want it to do
but it may be that there's like a core
which is
wanting to do what we want it to do with
like one layer of indirection
uh which if you can get that then the
rest of it
comes into place right
yeah I guess um and what do you think
about this as evidence I'm curious which
is that
For Better or Worse the human mind is
currently our only extant example of
a general intelligence okay it's not
artificial but I don't think that really
matters like it's it's a general
intelligence and if you believe in kind
of let's say the better angel or angels
of our nature you know the
um uh books like that right that explore
the humanity over time has been getting
better you know when you do have these
groups of
General intelligences these distributed
General intelligences it does seem that
cooperation and allyship tend to
outweigh you know uh Perpetual fighting
at least on average so
is that evidence for the the possibility
of that well or not really it's
uh
yeah I I don't know how compelling that
is it's not zero but basically it seems
as though this thing of like cooperation
is mostly about
um
it sort of emerges out of Game Theory if
you're playing iterated games with
players of like similar capabilities to
you then it just turns out that in our
world cooperation
works pretty well
um but there's no
particular expectation
like we don't behave very much better
towards agents which we don't have to
um
that we don't have to play this kind of
game theoretic thing with let me try and
say that again in a better way
um
this this applies to how we treat other
people
um
but that's because we have to play this
iterated game with other people if you
do nice things for people there is the
potential that they can do nice things
back and if you do mean things to other
people there's the potential that they
can do mean things back and therefore
in a fairly wide range of situations uh
it's better to be nice to people and
like yeah we've kind of discovered that
and
when you have you know technology and
development and so on then the pie is
growing and you don't have this
malthusian thing where the only way to
get more resources is to take them from
somebody else
um
and so on but it doesn't it doesn't
generalize that broadly so for example
we don't we treat animals
somewhat better
than we used to but not really like
factory farming is really really
horrendous and I think that's because
it doesn't matter how cruel you are to
chickens
they can come back
yeah but I think I think human you know
culture at least is is evolving to a
degree there and I mean you know we're
starting to real I mean we have nature
preserves and we try to protect you know
species now and and I think the majority
of us feel a great sense of like sadness
when some species goes extinct you know
we almost have an innate built-in
appreciation for Kenneth Stanley's point
that you need open-ended search and you
want to maintain as much variety as
possible really the variety in itself is
a is a good thing so I guess there's
maybe hope that a super intelligence
might evolve and even more refined you
know appreciation for variety and
open-ended existence you know yeah yeah
that doesn't give me very much hope I
have to say I think oh okay I think that
yeah I agree with you uh we do seem to
be doing better uh on that respect by
our own measure of what counts is better
obviously so there's definitely a
problem where like it looks like
progress judged from the effective of
the present but like from the
perspective of the past of course we're
morally doing terribly we don't we know
where
um
things like
um irreligiosity and sexual promiscuity
and all of these things which are great
great grandfathers would have been
appalled by you know uh
as morality shifts whatever this is not
the most important point the uh
the crap what is the most important
point
oh yeah right the orthogonality thesis
is the most important point
um
which is that at least in principle
any level of intelligence is compatible
with any goal
um you can design an AI system with any
goal that you like
and it will care about that goal
and there's no like level of
intelligence that it would that it could
reach that would result in it
wanting to change that goal
um
and so
it doesn't seem
certainly doesn't seem like anything we
can be confident of that
uh higher intelligence where again what
I'm talking about is capability
where like being better at picking
actions in the world that result in
particular outcomes according to your
preference ranking there's no level
of capability at that that results in
you changing your preference rankings
in any like predictable Direction
um
and in fact of course there's a pretty
strong instrumentally convergent goal to
keep your goals the same
um because if what you're doing is
deciding on actions according to what uh
what results in outcomes that achieve
your goal that like satisfy you know
that rank high in your preference
ordering then
um
when you evaluate the action of changing
your preference orderings
you think about what would happen in the
world what would happen if instead of
um wanting to maximize my reward I
actually wanted to like uh have people
be happy and thriving
say well the amount of reward I get
would be lower
so taking this action is not a good
action according to
the process that I use to decide on my
actions
so there's like a quite strong incentive
to not change your goals
and being smarter doesn't
just makes you better at getting what
you want
uh and if you don't want to change your
goals then that makes you better at not
having your goals changed
I mean just a very quick comment on that
I mean it still seems to me that you're
talking about incentives and goals and
agents and actions and so on and this is
anthropomorphic language this is our
conception of what an intelligent system
is
and it seems to say that it's got well
so who's to say that an intelligent
agent with a goal is descriptive of
intelligence
uh
I think we're going to build those
okay so it's what we're going to build
like it's it's it's descriptive of the
architectures
like I don't know like chat GPT is
trained with reinforcement learning
right
like we are explicitly building AI
systems in this framework so it's not an
unreasonable framework to use I think
the loophole here is that we believe at
least I'm assuming we believe that these
super intelligences are recursively
self-refining and continuing to learn
and so I think it's completely I believe
it's completely possible and probable in
fact that a super intelligence will will
learn that maintaining variety
is a helpful instrumental goal to
whatever you know whatever uh terminal
goal it's come up with because I think
there's just good mathematics for the
fact that maintaining variety
maintaining the open-endedness of your
your search you know that greatness
cannot be planned that it's a good thing
to maintain variety so like in the worst
case I think a super intelligence will
keep a zoo that contains like all the
forms of life you know that it's
discovered because it never knows that
they're going to be useful in the future
yeah yeah I I agree that it's like
plausible to me that there is some
instrumental uh instrumentally
convergent thing towards like not
destroying information that might be
relevant
um but I don't think that that gets us
very much at all
um
like
yeah probably it keeps a record of
the things that it dismantles just in
case it needs them again or something
but um this certainly doesn't result in
a universe that looks the way we want it
to be
um I'm not I'm not quite as pessimistic
but it's just going to keep it you know
an archive of genetic codes because I
think there's there's actually value in
allowing
the distributed systems to evolve but I
think we're both kind of guessing at
this point right is that fair I mean
yeah it's just that if you
looking at it in a an agent framework
which like I say is I think
reasonable it's not like um the be all
end all but I think it's a decent way of
thinking about these things
um
and it has some kind of goal
then there are various things that come
into play quite strongly
um
self-presentation is one goal
preservation is one
resource acquisition is one
um and like
yeah preserving previous information
is potentially in there
but it doesn't seem as strong as the
others it doesn't seem like it would
ever be a focus or that you would devote
a big chunk of your resources to that
kind of thing
well unfortunately I've I have to drop
as I as I mentioned earlier I know you
guys are going to continue a bit more
but it was a pleasure pleasure speaking
with you and I hope we did a good job of
Playing devil's advocate here so far
yeah it's been a lot of fun okay cool
because because I I think we should talk
more about um these topics we were just
about to get on to Super fascinating but
uh you know maintaining variety uh
distributed Evolution those sorts of
things but thank you so much it was a
pleasure talking with you thank you
cheers Keith so um I've I've got a few
more things I I want to talk about
actually I saved one of the best things
for last okay so I'm I'm really
interested in this concept of emergence
Yeah we actually made quite a
philosophical introduction to emergence
and um I guess um listeners can kind of
think of it as being a uh surprising
transient change in macroscopic
phenomena and there is um and by the way
language models are well known for
having these emergent capabilities so
when when you look at the perplexity uh
plot it just kind of like goes down but
what you notice is that at certain
points on that scale certain
capabilities emerge and this is another
form of orthogonality in a way because
because it's trained to do one thing but
we test it in another way and these
capabilities emerge now there was this
paper called our emergent abilities of
large language models a mirage and that
was by Ryland Schaffer etow at Stanford
and um they thought that these sharp and
unpredictable changes in model outputs
as a function of model scale and
specific tasks could be a mirage it
could be induced by the researcher's
choice of metric and we can talk about
good heart's law and the problems with
metrics in in general and um you know
and they said this is in spite of the
um the uh the the per token error rate
changing smoothly and continuously with
respect of increasing model size so um
they intentionally induced emergent
abilities in neural networks on
different architectures of of multiple
Vision tasks so um this raises some very
interesting questions I mean like how do
you think the idea of like a sudden
capability acquisition should be treated
in the context of alignment research and
do you think that somehow this concept
of an emergent capability and this
self-improving intelligence is related
yeah
um
so I should say you you did give me a
heads up that you were going to talk
about this paper but I only checked my
email like shortly oh that's okay
I haven't yet read this paper
um although I have I've seen some
discussion of it so I think I
have some idea of the gist but like I
say I haven't read it so I'm not going
to be able to
um that that's fine but I mean I guess
my thoughts yeah I mean look we could
abstract it a bit in the context of the
discussion which is that
um quite a few things are a mirage in
the sense of we have a certain cognitive
framework or we design metrics and we
see things that aren't really there
yeah so I think
I'm a little bit confused about what it
would mean
for emergent properties to not be a
mirage like it seems to me that what it
means
you say that they're unpredictable right
being unpredictable is an important
component
here
and then the question is like what
unpredictable to whom right it feels to
me that emergence is not a thing that
exists in the model or the behavior of
the model it's uh it exists between us
and the model it's a two-part function I
could imagine
like you could imagine you say like
rolling dice is unpredictable you could
imagine somebody smart enough to see the
dice rolling once they're already
rolling and like guess how that they're
gonna land
particularly well
but to me when I see the dice roll I
can't predict how they're going to land
and so they're random to me but it's not
like inherent to the nature of dice if
they are actually just following
deterministic physics
um and like I'm not making a big Claim
about the physics of the universe here
I'm saying that like even if you have
dice in a in a 3D game engine where the
physics is fully deterministic we still
can't predict them just by seeing how
they're thrown but you could
right and so to say
oh therefore they're not random it's
like
I don't know we can still play a game
with them we can't predict them that's
what matters right I mean to push back
on that a little bit I think it's better
to call it it's definitely related to
probability so it's surprise but I think
it's a surprising change in phenomena so
an example of this would be when we
started scaling up the the die let's say
we made a die which was as big as a
house and all of a sudden the
probabilistic characteristics changed
and we started seeing sixes all the time
okay so that would be an example of an
emerging property
yeah I'm not sure I'm following the
metaphor could we get more get less
abstract
uh well yes so um what's another good
example I mean so with with a language
model for example
um the idea is is that when we scale the
model up
um perplexity just kind of increases uh
or indeed decreases in respect of larger
models uh in in quite a smooth way not
necessarily a linear way but a smooth
way but but suddenly we just see these
jumps
and we have no idea why they why they
came to be
and these authors are basically arguing
that the the jumps aren't anything
intrinsic to the model they're just a
function of the way that we've crafted
the metrics
I see
yes and so if
this is like
what do I want to say about this
predicting is difficult especially about
the future
uh and so like
I don't know it feels kind of an unfair
thing to ask but like
was anything predicted before it
actually happened
or did we just look at it afterwards and
say ah in principle if we had done
things differently we could have
predicted it
well it's interesting because open AI
themselves they say when in their
technical report for gbt4 they said
we've got this amazing predictive model
of perplexity and the gpt4 model is
right inside our function that that we
that we designed it's bang on but the
thing that I thought was quite enticing
to
um x-risk people is that they said well
there's something we've got to be really
careful about here because if if the
perplexity goes down by just another
notch it might suddenly just acquire
this dramatic increase in capabilities
and that's why we need to be so
concerned about it
yeah yeah and that seems true like
so
I can see how by measuring things in
different ways you can get
discontinuities or continuous change
right and like obviously the way that
gradient descent works
the the the when you when you run back
propagation you're not changing any of
the weights by very much right you're
only doing it gradually and so obviously
nothing is going to instantaneously pop
out of that because all of the changes
are very small like if you zoom in far
enough it's going to be a pretty smooth
looking curve
but then you know yeah the question is
how useful is this can we actually can
we actually predict things so like
for example say you've got like um
you're testing its performance on a
multiple choice exam right
um
you can give it your 100 questions and
say oh I got you know this number of
them right or whatever but you could
also look at
what probability did it give each rather
than just saying like which which token
did it Give A B C or D you could say
what was the probability that it gave to
the correct token
and so you get this once the correct
token nudges past the second best
incorrect token now you have this
discontinuous jump of oh now it's giving
the right answer whereas before it was
giving the wrong answer but nonetheless
there was a continuous change that led
to that
right
and so yeah you can measure things
different ways that can
give you a better give you like a more
continuous view of things but then yeah
does this
I guess like it is potentially quite
uh quite exciting quite promising that
we might be able to do better at
predicting it just seems weird to say
that
the emergent is a mirage because
it happened right like
on the on the metric that we just that
we came up with not trying to make it
continuous so not trying to make it
discontinuous the metric we had that was
like the thing we care about this
Benchmark performance on this specific
Downstream task that we want AI systems
to do
at an unpredicted by us time it suddenly
jumped
so that happened
and then the question of like is it a
mirage
I mean
yeah very plausibly it could have been
predicted but we in fact did not predict
it and does this point to a way that we
could have
yeah it's interesting I mean I I guess
we should be careful to distinguish
convergence from emergence and so
emergence is definitely talking about
something which is surprising and
unexpected so for example with Cellular
automata in The Game of Life that's
definitely surprising and unexpected so
that's weekly emergent whereas you could
say having the capability of being able
to do I don't know compositional
reasoning and a language model maybe
that's not quite so surprising and
unexpected it seems like an observer
relative thing as well so you know
that's exactly my point it's an observer
relative thing that's the phrase that I
was searching for in the when I was
talking about Dice and so on it's it's
yeah it's yeah yeah okay okay well very
interesting
um we've got a couple of minutes not
read the paper
no worries at all
um okay okay
um just a bit of a slightly
controversial last question so some
people like Tim Nick gabrue bundle
together some of the X risk and maybe
not so much the alignment folks with
certain communities like effective
altruism transhumanism and rationalism
and so on and and in a way she's very
pejoratively saying that there's
elements of like cultic weirdness and
even utopianism and so on which is which
is quite disparaging I just wondered
whether you had a response to that kind
of criticism
not really
um I mean I'm
I think that we're being faced with
a real and serious problem that needs to
be dealt with
and I want to talk about that and try
and solve it
um
and talking about
who the people are and who they
associate with and all I don't know it's
just not
it feels like
it's not something I'm an expert on I
mean not that I'm really an expert on
any of this but like it's not something
I spend most of my time thinking about
and um
yeah I don't really I don't know
it's okay I mean I guess like they they
would say that there are real problems
around misinformation and bias and you
know like inequality and all sorts of
societal risks and absolutely and they
say
um
this ex absolutely and there's X risk
thing is kind of like taking up a lot of
the oxygen at the moment and they would
want to see more focus on the the near
term
yeah I think
uh
uh one thing is I don't really buy that
these are like directly in competition
there's a there's a thing that I
sometimes see people a phrase that I
sometimes see people use and I want to
arm people against this phrase which is
the real problem
right oh no the real problem is this
and any any chain of reasoning that uses
the phrase the real problem
is you're sneaking in an assumption by
the use of the right definite article
singular
that that there can only be one real
problem
we actually have several real problems
uh that all need to be dealt with
and um
trying to like avert these large-scale
Global catastrophic risks from AI
doesn't mean ignoring the short-term
ones there are some decent synergies
um there's like there's not a huge
overlap but there's definitely overlap
right like things that help us align
super intelligences probably help us
like avoid bias and discrimination and
all of these things in our in our
smaller systems as well right we're not
actually
on different teams here
we all want good outcomes for Humanity
it's not
it doesn't seem that productive to frame
it as a competition
or something where like it's we're all
on the same side I think
yeah I mean maybe like one perspective
is in a way there's been a huge success
of
um like the language from your community
has become ubiquitous so alignment and
people think of rlhf as being a form of
alignment and people are using that in
ethics circles now uh talking about how
we can make the models
um be less biased for example and so it
feels like there is a real fusion
between the communities now where
perhaps there wasn't before
yeah I think so I think it's just like
different
kinds of people with different life
experiences
have grabbed different parts of this
elephant
or something
uh and the Elephant is not really the
trunk and it's not really the tusks and
it's not really the the legs right
we've got we've grabbed a hold of like
hey
our AI systems are getting more and more
powerful more and more integrated into
society and we do not understand them
very well and we can't predict
accurately what's going to happen and we
don't have any kind of uh
coherent confidence that this is going
to work out well and this is a problem
and like this is a problem in a bunch of
different ways for a bunch of different
reasons uh and I don't
like this
it's just unproductive to
have infighting about that I think that
we just like need I get that obviously
there's like a finite amount of
attention in the world
but
it makes more sense to just direct more
of the world's attention towards this as
a whole
and everyone can get more of what they
need because we're not actually uh
we're not competing for a fixed
pie here
yeah okay and final question
um so so many people have they've been
following I mean you've been doing this
for years now and for many people their
first contact with you was through
computer file and in all of these years
that you've been doing this are there
any like topics that you've made videos
on and you've changed your opinion on
and are there any like big things that
that you've learned
yeah oh this is cool I can give two
Corrections
one thing is I made a video called
what's the use of utility functions
whereas basically explaining the volume
in Morgenstern theorems uh that suggest
that
any agent that doesn't have a consistent
utility function will be vulnerable to
uh like Dutch books and this kind of
thing
um
and all of that is true
but it kind of had an implication
that was not quite
not quite correct so
the observation is
any
agent with coherent preferences
must
have a can be represented by a utility
function
therefore thinking about agents maximum
agents maximizing a utility function
is a useful framework even if you don't
know even if the thing is not explicitly
programmed with a utility function and
so on
um
and the reason that this like and that's
true but I was kind of underestimating
how complicated the utility function is
allowed to be
and there's kind of a trivial case here
where you sort of observe the agent
get a record of everything that it ever
does
and then you say ah this is consistent
with the utility function of one utility
if you do that exact sequence and zero
otherwise
and now you've like got you know like in
principle now you have a utility
function that exactly maps to the thing
but this doesn't really tell you
anything there's kind of degenerate
cases
um
so that kind of thing like I didn't it's
frustrating because there's nothing I
said I've looked through I don't think I
said anything false in that video it's
true it is a theorem it's just the way
that the assumptions of the theorem map
onto reality make it somewhat less
broadly applicable than
you would assume
um but then it's also not a complete
write-off because like
there are kind of weakened forms if you
allow it to get fuzzier
right like the the phenomen Morgenstern
theorem is very like formal and rigid
whereas if you say look
anything that has existed in the world
I'm not going to do this properly
because I can't remember exactly how to
formulate this but like
the reason that it seemed plausible that
this rigid theorem applied is because
there's a much fuzzier version that
applies
in general for systems which for example
evolved in a competitive environment
like avoiding being Dutch booked is an
important thing that optimization
processes will push you towards because
being Dutch booked results in you losing
resources so
we do have this tendency
but at the actual theorem itself is not
yeah so I don't know I was thinking
about doing a follow-up video about that
that's just like it's money once than
that
um yeah
amazing well um Robert it's been such an
honor to have you on mlst and and I
would
um counsel all of our listeners to join
your Discord and to subscribe to your
YouTube if you haven't already and and
how else can can people
um you know find stuff from you Robert
yeah uh the the YouTube channel is good
uh I mean it's a good place to find more
stuff for me
um I also think it's good not the point
uh we are also working on a project
um aisafety dot info yeah we're also
trying to build a comprehensive FAQ
about AI safety which we're hosting at
aisafety dot info you can go and check
that out so
the idea is it's not really an FAQ it's
like an AQ we want to have answers to
just all the questions basically
um and you know usually with an FAQ you
have this problem of either being so
either being like short that you can
actually find your question but probably
doesn't actually have your question
or it's long enough but then it's so
long that you're not actually going to
read it you're going to get lost in the
thing so we are doing uh
we have like a built-in semantic search
you can ask your question and it will
propose similar uh similar questions
that have been answered or you can if if
your question isn't in the thing then
you can say ask this question and it
comes through and our community like on
the Discord will try to answer the
question and write a high quality answer
that then goes into the FAQ
um and then also each of the answers has
like related questions of other things
that you might be interested in and you
can kind of expand them out
um
and I recommend people to check that out
and get answers to all of their
questions
and also if you are a person who has
relevant expertise
um you can join in it's like a Wiki
right all of their questions have a
Google doc as their uh as their data
storage so you can just go in if you
spot a mistake or think something ought
to be changed just hit the pencil go
into Google Docs make a suggestion and
then our editors go through and evaluate
those in an ongoing basis to improve
their quality of the answers
yeah and I can personally vouch for it
so it was um one of our patreons and
Luna she's in our Discord Community
she's also in yours and the first thing
she said that I should do is go to AI
safety dot info I pinged Keith earlier
I've read through almost all of it now
it's it's really really well structured
it's fantastic so nice um I I think that
should be the the first Port of Call
actually for anyone who wants to learn
more about Asad so um yeah Robert thank
you so you might be interested wait one
last thing uh part of what we're trying
to do with that is uh provide a useful
data set to build a conversation agent
right because obviously obviously we are
so my hope is that uh sometime not too
long from now if you go to my
safety.info you can actually have an
ongoing conversation with a language
model based agent which is dynamically
pulling from the FAQ to get and and also
the literature and whatever else to get
the resources that it needs to hopefully
not hallucinate too much uh in
explaining AI safety Concepts that's the
problem we're still having problems with
hallucination we're working on it uh
also if you want to help out with that
and you know a lot about
um conversation agents then check out
the Discord and come come and say hi and
help us with it amazing yeah that's good
old retrieval augmented generation and I
can also recommend
um cohere have just released this new
um it's it's called a re-ranker but you
can use it as a ranker uh for doing that
kind of because obviously you need to
take embeddings and you need to rank
with a query and you can use that out of
the box and do some retrieval augmented
Generations so yeah nice
um definitely build that anyway Robert
thank you so much it's been an honor I
really appreciate it coming on thanks
it's been a lot of fun